we have to jump to this
massive very very important story here
oh boy from the daily mail exclusive
hunter biden could face prostitution
charges for transporting
hookers
across state lines and disguising checks
to them as payment for medical services
well i mean that's a medical it's a
medical center in many ways no
it's a medical health service it's a
medical service it's a prostate milk
yeah there you go yes her son spent 30
000 in five months on the girlfriend
experience
warning graphic content i'm not going to
show you the actual images but so this
is this is actually outside of the
icloud hack and the phone hack
apparently the feds have known that he
did this since 2019 of course so there's
is is anything really going to happen of
course not these people are as corrupt
as corrupt can be
but now that we know
do you think it's going to change
anybody's mind
i should have stressed this real quick a
suspicious activity report filed by
jpmorgan chase flagged transactions
involving moriva after she received tens
of thousands of dollars from hunter's
company so it was actually chase bank
that was like something undetected with
this and flagged it suspicious activity
uh i don't think anybody who knows
anything about the bidens is surprised
by any of this and i don't think anybody
believes there will be any
accountability or just well i don't know
this was this is one where like when
you're talking about prostitution people
in the cult everybody their ears perk up
and if this is actually there's evidence
that he did this and and
wasted i don't know if his taxpayer
money or whatever this is pretty much i
think it's i think it's actually
essentially fraud
maybe
look it's one thing for prostitution but
when you're bringing them to different
states that's when i say i've had enough
well but i was actually seriously gonna
ask that because i that's actually huge
huge
the the libertarian uh part of me i
think that uh prostitution should be
illegal i think that drug should be
legal but why are you take why are you
shuffling ladies of the night across the
state like why
why are you doing that what was it
boston in new york no but i actually
don't know like why why would you take
them across state lines
but hold on it's not like if you need a
like an umbrella it'll be there when you
get there yeah just get in the trunk
when you arrive i think this dude is
deeply disturbed and was abused and he's
he's like he's trying to emulate the
girlfriend experience
drug addict right right right he's just
he wants people to pretend like they
care about him man he's it's it's brutal
well yeah the girlfriend experience is
basically it is broken down to the fact
like it's not the girlfriend experience
of like two years in where you're
fighting right he just wants to be like
that would be a real bummer of a 30 000
yeah you spend it you're just arguing
about groceries like you stay at a hotel
there's all your stuff's on the lawn
well
but but you're right though that's what
it's about i mean it comes into the fact
that he was unloved as a child somebody
completely broke and hurt him and that's
what this comes down to i really believe
unloved as a child yeah well
no but even both
even if he was even if he wasn't abused
i think
what you're saying is just that form of
abandonment which probably happens a lot
with powerful parents like that you
would still it would still make sense
that you're reaching for drugs sex and
love addiction you know the only time
joe biden hugged his son was to sniff
him right now seriously yeah
or to push him out of the way to hug his
brother
he really was awful too hunter just
keeps putting on like pretty perfume to
get his dad to come sniff him and get
close he's wearing a girl's wig
his dad apparently funds all this stuff
yeah like there was another story where
hunt like this is this crazy thing uh
the bots really came out in force i
tweeted how is the media going to ignore
all these photos is that insane like the
photos that i have seen will give me
nightmares for the rest of my i have
ptsd right i i
yeah but it's like they're really awful
photos and videos and all of a sudden i
get inundated by weirdos defending
hundred bite and i'm like this is weird
why would anyone defend hundred you know
you don't have to like democrats to be
like like you can just stay quiet you
know or you you can say like i voted for
biden and i think this is really bad
because it is yes it's it's so weird of
course but the the defenses are weird
they're like hunter's not even a public
figure who cares and i'm like he flew on
air force two with his dad to do a
private equity deal with china and
secured the deal and now
uh joe biden has reportedly sold nearly
a million barrels of our crude to
sinopac a chinese-owned gas company that
hunter biden has his private equity firm
he founded co-founded has purchased 1.7
billion in significant marketing so it's
like yeah if hunter was just in like a
journey cover band in des moines it
would be fine but he is involved in this
stuff and this has been since right
after he left office as the vice
president i mean this has all been
happening since then it's actually
interesting because his lifestyle is
more in line with the journey journey
it really is expensive you know we can
actually save hunter right now join a
journey cover band and this will all go
away really more in line with like the
ex-drummer of a really great band
[Laughter]
i'm looking at the uh the trauma
in 1972 he was in a car accident with
his brother who was he was like two at
the time and his mom was in the car and
his sister who both died his mom's right
yeah he's saying in this interview with
people magazine that he didn't the
family never really talked about it so i
can imagine that being a source of like
maddening trauma if your dad never
mentions brutal yeah so rough i think it
may have something to do with
there's you know i don't know if it's
it's uh true or if it's just anecdotal
but my experience growing up is that the
kids in the suburbs who had wanted for
nothing did tons of drugs oh yeah
absolutely it was easy to fall into that
free time they were bored so for me in
detroit some of the richest kid i knew
the richest kids i knew they got
everything they wanted and didn't
appreciate anything they had no purpose
yeah i i forgot about this story until
we started
i've been also triggered by hunter biden
uh i smoked crack once by accident where
it was with this rich kid who would come
to our house sometimes and i was just a
weed guy i never did hard drugs and
we're smoking this was bunter hiding
bunter hiding
what was that simpsons uh l simpson no
no that's too obvious lisa s
um the
uh
and i was smoking and i was like yeah i
feel kind of weird man and he looks at
me and again this was like the rich kid
and he looks at me and just goes oh yeah
there may be a little crack in that and
i was like buddy there's no such thing
as a little crack you either smoked no
crack or you are now addicted to crack
and i was just like what is it and yeah
i did but yeah i was the pr we were
suburbs we were the poor kids in the
suburbs but all the people who were
doing hard drugs were the rich kids in
our area yeah we were just smoking bad
weed and seeing fish legit though the
scary thing right now is the the lacing
of drugs yes oh the fen it's horrible
yeah fentanyl there was like tons of
story i saw a story was like an 18 year
old kid thought he was gonna party and
he took in some fentanyl not realizing
that's what that yeah there were a
couple comics she died it was a big
story in like comedy community that
there's like three of them in the house
yeah i've lost eight friends in two
years defending them
what's your take being in recovery on
um
like the strips to test because it's one
of those things where it's like we
shouldn't have to we obviously don't
want to encourage people to do drugs but
like i think it's a good idea you have
to remember the first time i thought i
was on a new york subway and i was like
oh that's nice you know test your drugs
for drugs right
and uh but yeah i think it's it's better
than nothing because now it's it's it's
put in there well it's put in there from
china given to mexican cartels put into
your stuff to make it more potent and
people say well why would you want to
kill your clientele it's like there's no
shortage of addiction
right you can make new ones every day
right but i also think that china's
intent is actually just the
destabilization and destruction of the
country 100 percent the opium wars are
still active right
what's the strip you're talking about
this drug detection strip uh it actually
tests your drink you can put it into
your cocaine and it'll tell you if
you're spending wow it's just a piece of
like a strip that turns a color so yeah
but you can you can miss it though too
because fentanyl is so little i mean the
tiniest amount right yeah
i i think we need to um do uh
drug abstinence abstinence only yes
that's correct don't do drugs don't yeah
i agree with you you gotta you gotta
define the word drug fentanyl is an
insidious dangerous chemical i mean i
gotta be at the beginning too like we're
going towards more military upgraded
drugs it's gonna be like buff out from
fallout you guys ever play like these
crazy psychoactive strength inducing
addictive things we got to watch out for
and they're just making more and more in
laboratories as they do lasers
bioshock is a better better example
stuff that twists your dna and makes you
like feral crazy i mean yeah we need
better drugs yeah that's right well
that's what i'm aiming for is better
drug
but like doctor prescribed better
functioning
no bad side effects no bodily
destruction or whatever even even not
what's used to peacefully put down
elephants
even with psychedelics they're doing it
uh medically now it's you're with a
therapist and their mdma treatments
um even with psilocybin and it's
helping for ptsd for depression but it
is not oh i'm doing mushrooms and going
to hooters with the boys on friday it is
literally you are sitting with a
therapist there taking notes it is look
look ibuprofen you can get over the
counter and it's fantastic i hurt my
back a couple weeks ago i couldn't even
move it was brutal and took a bunch of
them and it really helped yeah you
wanted to be careful with that stuff
because it'll rip your your muscles up
against yourself i get heartburn every
time i take it yeah exactly it stops
your body from producing like mucus or
whatever yeah so your stomach will
digest itself if you do too much of it
that's why it's like
yo you got to talk to a doctor i know
it's not good
yeah and uh non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories yeah
i get unless i i yeah i got heartburn i
can't take like aspirin or advil it like
tears my stomach up yeah everything
created by man is to kill you it's
terrible it's the worst well no it's
just like it's just there's a there's a
you got you gotta you gotta pay you
gotta pay your dues yeah they're like if
you want the pain to go away there's a
there's a limit to how much you can
actually accommodate with with uh
anything yeah you know too much exercise
is bad for you you gotta you gotta rest
days eating too much meat you get the
meat sweats you get sick you might barf
water electrolyte displacement building
technology to destroy or consume things
more efficiently like the fork the fork
is great at putting a dead animal's body
into your mouth yeah so the saw is
fantastic at killing a tree so that you
can make wood at wooden structures out
of it like we're we're really uh we're
really innovative when it comes to
destroying
better ways to destroy we're better than
the beaver
oh yeah yeah and they're pretty all
right they wrecked stuff these are are
good tear it up good mm-hmm straight up
never seen a damn i'm like damn oh yeah
oh that's why they call them that i
think so i think this is the first one
who saw so thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you